Oh danced chewy flavorless old fever hi
I'm Alexis and I'm always up for a
challenge that's why I've taken to the
Internet to decide what appliance I
should use to make a three-course meal
at the end a surprise guest will come on
and they'll have to guess what I used to
cook with we've gone through the
comments from our previous episodes and
you've chosen what I'm gonna use let's
check it out
not bad not bad
this feels like the most closest thing
to actually cooking that I've used so
far that's that I haven't used a toaster
oven and like over a decade so who knows
back in the early days of tasty they had
a really small kitchen and they were
just using toaster ovens so if they can
do it so can i right so my producer is
graciously let me do a bit of research
we know how it went when I didn't get
you last time so Oh
let me see what they have to say toaster
ovens have a lot of hot spots so it's
really important to rotate the pan as
you're going really good tip probably
wouldn't done it hey check this out huh
okay they have a broiled that's big this
goes
[Music]
okay feels good I've chosen my recipes I
feel like I have kind of a handle on how
this works it's gonna be challenging but
I think I have some good ideas I'm
pretty excited so I'm starting off with
dessert I'm making a strawberry
shortcake
I made it four times than I can count I
actually made these biscuits for a tasty
101 about grilled desserts and they're
really easy they're really great so
that's not really what worries me I know
it goes up to 450° which is amazing
that's all I need but I'm just kind of
skeptical that this is gonna get an even
baked all the way through so first
things first I'm gonna preheat the
toaster oven I'm adding two cups of
flour quarter cup of sugar teaspoon of
salt little salt actually helps enhance
the flavor and will actually make it
sweeter and more delicious two
tablespoons of baking powder
so just whisk it all together look how
easy this is I've got frozen butter here
and I'm gonna grade it with a cheese
grater this is a really easy way to get
it evenly combined with the flour and
then you just toss it adding the milk
could also use buttermilk combined it to
make this kind of shaggy dough one of
the perks is that it doesn't have to
rest you're just gonna fold it over a
few times that's gonna create layers
five or six times is enough more than
that is actually gonna kind of like
squash the butter okay so this is a
really fun protip fun for me so if you
dip your cookie cutter in some flour
press down and then take it immediately
up so no twisting it'll actually help
prevent the layers from getting smushed
and create like a really airy biscuit
I'm gonna brush them with a little bit
of milk the milk is just gonna give them
a glossy finish on top you could use
heavy cream you could do an egg wash and
then I'm just gonna sprinkle a little
bit of sugar on top
that's a nice texture that's a little
sweetness okay these look really good
I'm gonna bake it for six minutes and
internet reminded me to flip it halfway
that and then see what happens well my
biscuits baked I'm gonna work on
macerating my strawberries so they get
nice and flavorful I'm just gonna add
sugar to the strawberries so we're just
gonna break them down over a few hours
and make them soft and juicy I'm gonna
add some lemon zest and juice just to
add a bit of acidity I think in order to
really elevate this and kind of WoW and
surprise my taste testers I should add
balsamic to its a few drops I don't want
it to be overwhelmingly sweet like
saccharine sweet I just want it to be I
want it to taste like my birthday when I
was five
it's not too much to ask okay the
biscuits look like they're getting
pretty brown on top that look fairly raw
okay they're fully wrong the middle so
or time I think this could be one of the
downsides of a toaster oven is that it's
so hot that the top is getting kind of
scorched and the middle isn't fully
cooking but you know I don't want to
make judgments too soon might be fine
because the toaster oven is my only
appliance I need to whip cream by hand
here we go again
oh the biscuits look like they're
getting really dark maybe it's okay well
honestly it looks beautiful it looks
like fluffy and light right wait it's a
little touch-and-go at the temperature
but they are obviously perfect done one
thing hmm for my second course I'm going
to make a skirt steak with crispy
potatoes and a blue cheese compound
butter usually if I was making breasts
potatoes I would parboil them and water
before it's obviously not option so I've
got to cook them raw hard boiling just
helps make the inside really light and
fluffy and the exterior really crispy
hopefully I can achieve that by
completely omit any stuff I'm going to
cut my potatoes into smaller parts so
they will take less time rosemary
easy easy easy salt and pepper I'm just
gonna toss it together look beautiful
beautiful beautiful well when this heats
up these will be ready to go in the
meantime I'm gonna make a blue cheese
try of compound butter and a compound
butter is basically just infusing butter
with other flavors chilling it I love
blue cheese I love all cheese like yes
it is pungent you know I think people
get afraid of things because of certain
lengths Mallos or it's like oh that's
weird it's mold
but like spoiler all cheese's mold I was
just gonna you know kind of mash this up
but my butter looks a little stiff so
maybe if I just put it on top of the
toaster oven it'll melt a little
this was so smart so smart it's like the
perfect consistency I love to his Romans
who knew that it really incorporated so
that the flavors everywhere and you're
not just taking like one big bite of
bleu cheese and then a bite of butter
and then I'm gonna roll it into a log
okay see it doesn't look great yeah
but if you kind of fold it down
beautiful gonna give these potatoes a
try huh it's really nice it's really
good they look great they look happy my
potatoes are chirping they're making
little crispy potato sense honestly
confidence level is maybe an 8.5 maybe a
9 maybe it's a 9 I'm gonna make a really
simple marinade for my skirt steak some
garlic oil salt pepper
I thought skirt steak because it's so
thin you would be pretty easy to cook in
a toaster oven for the steak I'm going
to try and broil it timer for 5 minutes
it's definitely cooking looks a tiny bit
gray
I mean grainy isn't super appealing to
me let me just check the cook on this I
mean it looks really good
skirt steak is so thin it's really easy
to overcook so you want it to be pink in
the middle
ha if your touch chewy the flavor is
really good it's just that the mired
reaction creates this crust
it creates the flavor and it's just kind
of gray right now what okay okay what if
I put a cast iron pan pre heated it in
here and then cook the steak in the cast
iron it's gonna test it on another piece
of steak and we'll see what happens it's
oh it's actually like starting to smoke
which might be good for me so I'm just
gonna put the steak right on okay this
is boudin very well oh man didn't do
anything no somehow made it to here what
are we gonna do
my confidence level on the steak it is
like a five good flavor
bad texture new idea I'm going to take
the rack from another toaster oven put
it on the second floor put the tray
underneath and then put the steak
directly on the rack no matter what
happens with this round have to make it
work I really don't want to serve rubber
steak but if I have to cover it with a
lot of compound butter okay I think my
steak is done oh this is so weird you
know it's not the prettiest thing I've
ever made that's for sure I think this
is as good as it's gonna get though and
I have to move on so I'm just gonna go
and let this rest on the side I still
love the toaster oven but I guess it
can't do everything so for my appetizer
I'm going to do a baked calamari
normally I would deep-fry this and get
it really crispy delicious
you know Dipple Bowl I'm not sure
that's gonna happen in a toaster oven
but we'll see if I can get something
close to it that's a mixed calamari
tubes and tentacles I know that people
can get really freaked out by the
tentacles but it's part of the animal
gonna dip it in flour first then egg and
then panko after my steak snafu my
confidence level is is dwindling right
now okay moment of truth
I have it at 450 which is the highest
that this toaster oven goes and I'm
gonna give it five ten minutes I imagine
will be closer to ten but I've never
baked calamari before so looks a little
weird calmer ilex crispy in some places
it doesn't exactly look fried but big
calamari not a thing for a reason I'm
gonna move on to my holy so I'm just
grating some garlic into some egg yolks
add a bit of mustard which is gonna help
emulsify it a little salt whisk to
combine so the trick with making an
aioli is to go drop by drop if you add
too much oil to begin with it's never
going to form an emulsion and it's gonna
break and be blue so you want it to be
like thick and Dibble I mean like
literally a drop and risk
[Music]
add some lemon juice it's beautiful it's
really good let's say
this is not good dense chewy flavorless
all three of us so my guests multiple
are on the way and so I've gotta start
plating and hope for the best
I feel like I started really strong here
and honestly just plummeted starting hi
I'm Claudia and I'm Adam and back in the
day 2015 when tasty just started Adam
and I were two of the original producers
before it's the tasty kitchens that you
guys know today we were cooking in the
original BuzzFeed Studios which did not
have an oven or a stove so we were
relying on hot plates microwave toaster
oven alexis has cooked with a lot of
crazy stuff in the past so I'm really
excited to see what she's made for us
today
I am as ready as I'll ever be
good to see you huh how'd it go you know
I'll let you be the judge of that
of course number one we've got baked
calamari and aioli
so it's baked yes let me I dunked it in
mayonnaise okay so more exciting than
baked calamari we've got and combat
butter and crispy potatoes it looks
amazing
taters look auspiciously really good hmm
unfair that whatever you use your evil
make this meal I kind of forgot where
it's supposed to be guessing what the
appliances that I'm like to sit yeah I
miss into the meal now this is how it
would look
yeah I got the proper tools right on a
scale of 1 to 10 how would you rate this
object
solid eight yeah much more exciting
strawberry shortcake he's a master in
berries some hand whipped cream and your
very own strawberry shortcake is made
with what appliance what finds do you
think well everything so well browned
and like cooked you did use an iron one
time though and that looked pretty damn
good I would not have guessed that in a
million years
want a lawnmower definitely longer like
a toaster like a slotted toaster you're
not far off autumn I chose this toaster
oven okay that's impressive I love that
because I used to make a lot of early
tasty stuff and like I have always after
doing that been a proponent of like if
you have a hot plate a toaster oven you
can do anything I mean it would be
concerning if it was just as good as if
you didn't have all right oh oh get a
to-go box that was amazing
congratulations oh it's so kind I did it
Adam and Claudia were so generous with
their feedback they were so encouraging
and supportive they seemed to like
everything I made so you know my
takeaway is that I am my own worst
critic
and I feel excited for the rest of the
season for whatever else you're gonna
throw at me if you make anything in a
toaster oven
tag me I'd love to see what you can do
and comment below - guess what appliance
is gonna be next
[Music]